la séance est ouverte
le compte-rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée nous
n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en séance
je n'en vois pas
le procès-verbal est adopté sous les
réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues notre ordre du jour rappelle
les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmise en direction publique Sénat
et sur d'autres sites Internet
chacun sera attentif au respect des uns
et des autres et à celui du temps de
parole et je donne immédiatement la
parole au président Guillaume Gontard
pour le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre le prince Président
nous a gratifié à leur méridienne de sa
bonne parole totalement hors sol il a
annoncé continué à avancer à marche
forcée totalement hors sol il a osé
comparer l'un des plus grands mouvements
populaires de notre histoire à la
sédition factieuse des suprématistes
blancs envahissant le Capitole
totalement hors sol il a insulté les
manifestants et les manifestants sans
avoir un mot pour condamner les
exactions de la police qui sous vos
ordres tabasse nasse jette des grenades
en pleine tête roulent à moto sur les
gens intimides et arrête n'importe qui
n'importe quand sur le regard à l'armée
du Défenseur des droits totalement hors
sol et a plu à une incohérence près il a
tout de même reconnu que cette réforme
était brutale et surtout incomplète
qu'elle ne s'intéressait ni à la réalité
du travail ni à la pénibilité ni aux
fins de carrière ni aux reconversion
alors madame la Première ministre avec
gravité avec inquiétude nous vous le
demandons solennellement revenez à
l'héréiter et retirer cette réforme
avant d'avoir un drame sur la conscience
quand vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Guillaume Gontard
après des semaines où l'on a pu voir
beaucoup de postures il est temps de
rappeler quelques vérités oui cette
réforme est nécessaire pour assurer
l'avenir de nos retraites
sans elle les déficits se seraient
accumulés et nous aurions été contraints
à des hausses d'impôts ou des baisses de
pension au détriment des plus modestes
et des classes moyennes
oui cette réforme a fait l'objet de
concertation intense avec le ministre du
Travail Olivier du soft depuis l'automne
dernier nous avons rencontré les
organisations syndicales et patronales
et les groupes parlementaires à de
nombreuses reprises et le projet a
considérablement évolué grâce à ses
concertations et oui cette réforme est
le fruit d'un débat parlementaire long
et dense avec plus de 175 heures en
séance et un accord trouvé en commission
mixte paritaire et oui le compromis
fonctionne nous avons travaillé ensemble
bâti un projet qui reprend des
propositions que la majorité
sénatoriale portée parfois depuis
longtemps mais aussi des idées qui
n'étaient pas les vôtres
issus de l'assemblée et ce projet vous
l'avez adopté par deux fois à une large
majorité je veux saluer les membres de
la majorité sénatoriale et ceux qui
soutiennent l'action du Président de la
République pour leur engagement au
service de notre modèle social enfin oui
nous avons respecté l'esprit et la
lettre de la Constitution et nous sommes
arrivés au terme du cheminement
parlementaire de cette réforme et en
revanche non on ne peut pas brader
l'intérêt général par démagogie ou par
peur de l'impopularité et non les
violences ne sont pas excusables et je
veux rendre hommage à nos policiers et
nos gendarmes pour leur engagement au
service de l'ordre républicain
monsieur le monsieur le Président
Gontard comme l'a dit le président de la
République tout à l'heure nous entendons
les doutes et les colères qui
s'expriment dans les mouvements sociaux
et qui dépasse largement la question des
retraites je pense à cette demande de
justice et nous devons veiller à ce que
les travailleurs bénéficient davantage
des profits exceptionnels de certaines
entreprises je pense aux attentes de nos
concitoyens dans leur rapport au travail
à notre capacité à prévenir l'usure
professionnelle et à offrir des
perspectives de carrière à chacun nous
devons continuer sur le chemin de la
réindustrialisation et du pleine emploi
car il permettront d'assurer notre
souveraineté et l'avenir de notre modèle
social nous devons veiller à l'ordre
républicain avec des moyens
supplémentaires pour nos forces de
l'ordre et notre justice nous devons
permettre à nos compatriotes de vivre
mieux en prenant des décisions aux
effets sensibles rapides en travaillant
avec nos collectivités sur la santé sur
l'éducation sur la transition écologique
autour de ce cap le président de la
République m'a chargé d'engager un
travail avec tous les parlementaires qui
veulent agir pour notre pays nous en
sommes capables nous l'avons montré
encore récemment en bâtissant des
majorités de projets autour de la loi
sur les énergies renouvelables ou encore
hier à l'Assemblée nationale sur le
nucléaire mais monsieur le Président
comptard dans des périodes d'inquiétude
l'immobilisme n'est jamais la solution
je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est pas
pour vous répondre réplique madame la
Première ministre sortait de votre
posture de votre déni et revenez à la
réalité je vous croyais plus lucide que
le président même les ressorts
autoritaires de nos constitutions d'un
autre temps sont brisés vous ne pouvez
pas gouverner en technocrate de palais
contre le peuple nous sommes entrés
cette semaine dans un de ces moments
récurrent de notre histoire ou le fleuve
de la colère populaire est sorti de son
lit seul le pouvoir exécutif peut enta
rire la source et rétablir le calme
retirez votre réforme européenne et
remettez tout à plat le travail la
retraite comme la lui-même annoncé le
président tout à l'heure et tant que
vous y êtes lancé aussi la refonte de
nos intestus des institutions
anachroniques pour que les mots du
Président j'ai le sens de la démocratie
ne soit pas un énième mensonge une
énième provocation vous n'avez de toute
façon plus de majorité pour faire autre
chose
la parole est à notre collègue Colette
mélo pour le groupe Les Indépendants
République et territoires vous avez la
parole
le président de la République a rappelé
à plusieurs reprises combien il était
essentiel à notre souveraineté que nous
puissions de nouveau produire en France
nous partageons ce constat et nous avons
soutenu le gouvernement dans la prise de
mesure destinée à favoriser le retour de
l'industrie sur notre sol notamment par
la baisse des impôts de production
aujourd'hui le chef de l'État vient
d'annoncer la mise en place prochaine
d'une contribution des entreprises en
faveur des salariés monsieur le ministre
dans un contexte où nous entreprises ont
autant besoin d'être rassuré que nos
concitoyens pourriez-vous nous donner
des éclaircissements quant à ce nouveau
dispositif s'agit-il d'une nouvelle taxe
comment la compétitivité et la capacité
d'investissement de nos entreprises
seront-elles préservées
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole des taux
ministres de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique vous avez la parole monsieur
le ministre merci monsieur le Président
Madame et messieurs les sénateurs
totalement votre objectif de trouver le
bon équilibre entre la compétitivité des
entreprises notamment de notre industrie
et la nécessité de mieux partager la
valeur pour les salariés pour que tous
ceux qui travaillent on est tout
simplement pour leur engagement c'est ce
que nous avons fait depuis 6 ans nous
avons simplifié l'intéressement
simplifier les accords de participation
nous avons supprimé la taxe à 20% qui
pesait sur les accords d'intéressement
de participation nous avons mis en place
avec le président de la République la
prime défiscalisée jusqu'à 6000 euros
pour redistribuer de la valeur pour les
salariés nous avons également demandé à
toutes les entreprises qui bénéficient
de rente je pense aux entreprises
énergéticiennes de redistribuer cette
rente à travers la contribution sur la
rente inframarginale qui
plusieurs milliards d'euros et qui
financent le bouclier énergétique que
nous avons mis en place avec la première
milice la proposition du Président de la
République c'est la troisième étape de
cette meilleure répartition de la valeur
entre le salarié et l'entreprise nous
voulons que les entreprises qui font du
rachat d'action donc qui ont donc les
moyens de le faire contribuent davantage
à la meilleure rémunération des salariés
nous voulons donc les obliger à
distribuer plus d'intéressement plus de
participation plus de primes
défiscalisées lorsqu'elles font du
rachat d'action nous voulons que ce soit
substantiel nous pourrions envisager par
exemple un doublement des sommes versées
au titre de la participation de
l'intéressement ou des primes des
fiscalisées pour toutes les grandes
entreprises qui font du rachat d'action
de quelles entreprises parlons-nous les
grandes entreprises celles qui ont plus
de 5000 salariés et celles qui font du
rachat d'action quelle est la méthode
que nous privilégions avec la première
ministre c'est celle d'une proposition
qui est faite aux partenaires sociaux
pour qu'il négocie sur cette meilleure
participation ce meilleur intéressement
cette distribution plus large d'actions
pour les grandes entreprises qui ont
recours à ces actions gratuites voilà la
proposition que nous faisons le rachat
d'action pardon voilà la proposition que
nous faisons avec après un ministre et
avec le président de la République pour
un meilleur partage de la valeur madame
mélo
merci monsieur le ministre de nous avoir
rappelé les mesures qui avaient déjà été
prises et les nouvelles mesures dont
nous attendons bien sûr beaucoup de
retombées avec de nouvelles une nouvelle
répartition avec une contribution des
grandes entreprises afin que des
intéressements et une participation
puisse améliorer les conditions de vie
de nos concitoyens merci merci la parole
est à notre collègue Serge bavary pour
le groupe les républicains
[Musique]
le 19 janvier dernier j'ai interrogé le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
sur les difficultés de fonctionnement du
guichet unique des entreprises mis en
place le 1er janvier sa réponse était
alors voulue rassurante le dispositif
serait corrigé dans les toutes
prochaines semaines avec une échéance
fixée au début du mois de mars pas plus
tard depuis cette échéance est sans
cesse repoussée
sur votre suggestion madame la ministre
notre délégation aux entreprises s'est
déplacée alienpi le 8 février dernier et
nous avons pu constater l'ampleur et la
complexité de la tâche en dépit de
solutions temporaire tels que la
réouverture d'un fogrès ce service de
simplification continue de
dysfonctionner jusqu'à compromettre en
particulier l'avenir de la filière
artisanale première difficulté le
registre national des entreprises n'est
pas fiable et ne comporte aucune mention
d'appartenance au secteur des métiers et
la qualité artisanale les chambres de
métiers sont dans l'incapacité de
fournir des extraits d'inscription
issue du Registre national la synthèse
obtenue après validation n'étant pas
reconnue par les partenaires banque et
assureurs
deuxième difficulté la complexité du
système de catégorisation les
entreprises artisanales ne sont tout
bonnement plus identifiées l'alerte est
donnée les chambres des métiers ne
peuvent plus exercer leur mission de
contrôle elles sont contraintes de
maintenir leur logiciel métier en
doublon du guichet unique ce qui
représente un coup important le réseau
des CM1 a formulé les propositions
madame la ministre quelle suite allez
vous y donner quelle mesure allez vous
prendre pour fiabiliser le registre issu
du guichet unique et permettre une
meilleure identification de l'activité
et de la qualification artisanale je
vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole est à la ministre délégué chargé
des petits des moyens d'entrepris du
commerce et de l'artisanat
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Babarit vous le savez depuis
le 1er janvier nous travaillons
constamment à rendre le guichet unique
totalement opérationnel pour les
formalités d'entreprise et effectivement
on en a parlé ensemble et je vous
remercie d'ailleurs au sujet de la
délégation des entreprises d'avoir pris
le temps d'aller voir aussi les équipes
de l'INPI pour mesurer leur engagement
le déploiement il se poursuit à date
nous dénombrons plus de 470 000
formalités création et modifications il
y a pas aujourd'hui et vous le savez
monsieur le Président Babari de
problèmes sur les créations on a en
revanche très clairement encore des
difficultés sur les formalités de
modifications et de cessation d'activité
hier on a franchi une nouvelle étape
avec la bascule des formalités de
cessation sur le guichet unique ce qui
nous rapproche et garantit l'objectif de
parvenir à un outil unique d'ici à la
fin juin pour autant il existe des
marges d'amélioration vous les avez
mentionnées monsieur le président
babaris notamment sur le traitement des
déclarations des entreprises artisanales
je pense au problème des
multi-validations les cas dans lequel un
artisan doit obtenir la validation de
ces données par la CMA mais aussi par le
greffier du tribunal de commerce mais
services ce sont saisis du sujet les
travaux accélère pour améliorer et
faciliter le partage d'information la
qualité est la précision du registre
national des entreprises est aussi un
enjeu ce registre que vous connaissez a
été conçu pour regrouper les données
toutes les entreprises il est légitime
que les entreprises du secteur des
métiers et de l'artisanat soient
clairement identifiés en tant que tel au
sein du registre il y a des
insuffisances encore à date au sein du
registre là aussi nous accélérons et
nous travaillons pour les corriger le
plus rapidement possible enfin vous
l'avez mentionné la catégorisation la
catégorisation monsieur le Président
barbarie je veux quand même dire qu'elle
a été bâtie et définie avec tous les
partenaires du projet dont cm à France
soyons clairs c'est un des enjeux les
plus importants les plus complexes pour
le fonctionnement du guichet unique
l'engagement du ministère de l'économie
est total vous l'avez dit le 8 février
vous y êtes allé monsieur le Président
babary comme tous les projets
informatiques d'ampleur il est complexe
on sera au rendez-vous fin juin je vous
remercie
vous avez quelques secondes
madame la ministre la difficulté
principale c'est que ça devait être
opérationnel au 1er janvier et que
depuis trois mois les entreprises ont de
grandes difficultés non plus à
s'inscrire comme vous l'avez dit mais à
faire quelques modifications que ce soit
ou pour les artisans à pouvoir être pris
en considération pour leur relation avec
les banques les assureurs et autres
intervenants donc il faut faire au plus
vite et je l'avais indiqué à monsieur le
ministre
c'est une difficulté de simplifier mais
la numérisation ne règle pas tout merci
la parole est au président Jean-François
Longeot pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste vous avez la parole monsieur
le président
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse aux ministres de
l'économie il y a deux jours le GIEC
publiait la synthèse de son sixième
rapport un document très attendu et qui
résonne comme un coup de ce Mons
l'humanité est au pied du mur face au
réchauffement climatique c'est agir ou
périr notre gouvernement à l'Union
européenne en ont bien conscience ce
dont témoignent les efforts
d'accélération de la transition
environnementale bonjour or aujourd'hui
même sort une étude relative à l'impact
sur l'emploi que risque d'avoir cette
transition dans notre pays un travail
qui émane du Centre d'études prospective
et d'information internationales
un service qui dépend de Matignon et
dont la qualité des travaux n'est plus à
démontrer selon cette étude la
transition écologique pourrait avoir le
même effet que la désintustrialisation
ayant lieu depuis 1997 alors où Bercy
achève la co-construction de son projet
de loi pour un industrie verte le
problème est crucial les auteurs de
l'étude soulignent que selon la
Commission européenne entre 35 et 40%
des emplois pourraient être touchés par
la transition écologique la question clé
est de savoir s'il pourra y avoir une
réallocation de main de fluide entre les
secteurs gagnants c'est à dire les
secteurs décarbonés et les secteurs
polluants en état actuel des choses rien
n'est moins sûr car jusqu'ici les plans
sociaux ne se sont jamais faits s'encas
humaine au moins pour les travailleurs
les moins qualifiés qui ont toujours
peiné à retrouver un emploi et encore
plus à ne pas subir une importante
baisse de salaire
monsieur le ministre ma question est
donc simple comment anticipez-vous le
problème de la mutation nécessaire de
l'emploi dans le cadre de la transition
vers une industrie verte je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique sur le
ministre monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs hélas trois
fois hélas il y a pas eu besoin d'avoir
une transition climatique pour qu'il y
ait des délocalisations industrielles de
masse depuis trois décennies dans notre
pays la faute française elle est là
2 millions d'emplois industriels
détruits depuis les années 80 des
usines qui ferment absolument partout
une richesse nationale et une part de la
production industrielle dans la richesse
nationale qui passe de 20% à juste un
peu plus de 10%. ça c'est trois
décennies de politique
anti-industriels qui entraîné cette
délocalisation avec le président de la
République depuis 2017 nous avons pris
les mesures nécessaires pour obtenir des
résultats la première décision que nous
ayons prise c'est de baisser l'impôt sur
les sociétés c'est de baisser les impôts
de production c'est de mettre en place
un prélèvement forfait ironique parce
que il n'y a pas d'industrie son capital
baisser la fiscalité sur le capital
c'est augmenter l'industrialisation du
pays voilà les vérités que personne ne
voulait voir en face résultat nous
ouvrons aujourd'hui plus d'usine que
nous enfermons et nous recréons pour la
première fois du 3 décennies 88000
emplois industriels depuis deux ans en
France et je vais vous dire ma
conviction la transition climatique est
une chance pour notre industrie nous
allons avec le ministre de l'Industrie
proposé une loi sur l'industrie verte
qui va favoriser la commande publique
pour les produits industriels Verts
français et européens nous allons mettre
en place des crédits d'impôts et des
mesures fiscales plus fortes pour tous
ceux qui travaillent dans l'hydrogène
vert dans les batteries électriques dans
les panneaux solaires dans les véhicules
électriques pour favoriser la création
d'emploi vers et industriels dans notre
pays nous allons faire en sorte
d'accélérer l'ouverture des usines et
l'extension des usines vertes existantes
pour accélérer les relocalisations
industrielles et accélérer les créations
d'emplois nous devons conjuguer
croissance et climat c'est ce qui a
toujours été la ligne de force du
gouvernement de la Premier ministre et
du président de la République les
résultats sont là nous allons accélérer
que le président Longeot
la parole est à notre collègue Michel
gréaume pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologique il y
avait la parole le Président Monsieur le
Ministre un peuple refuse de
se vœu le recul à
74 à la retraite face au mouvement
social massif qui porte l'exigence de
retrait face à une Assemblée nationale
qui n'a voté la réforme ni en première
lecture ni en seconde lecture vous vous
enfermez avec le président de la
République dans un repli autoritaire
lourd de danger pour la démocratie vous
avez affirmé vouloir aller au bout du
cheminement démocratique quelle
provocation c'est bien un chemin de
croix auquel nous assistons rythmé par
les articles désormais connus de tous 47
à 44 3 49.3 monsieur le ministre comment
parler de cheminement démocratique alors
que depuis jeudi le droit de manifester
est mis en cause avec mon groupe je
demande que soit mis à l'étude le
comportement des forces de sécurité
depuis jeudi soir il ne s'agit pas de
cautionner des dégradations mais nous
assistons à des violences policières et
réquisitions inacceptable le maintien de
l'ordre de votre responsabilité mais
l'ordre ce n'est pas le matraquage et
gazage à tout va c'est savoir entendre
la foule l'opinion le peuple qui dit non
la colère est là elle monte la morgue et
le mépris du chef de l'État ne passeront
pas cette fois-ci à la répression
policière ne peut être la voie pour
résoudre cette crise politique sociale
très profondes le chef de l'État droit
dans ses bottes ne veut ni dissolution
ni référendum ni remaniement qu'il
retire alors ce projet si injuste si par
malheur monsieur Macron ne veut assumer
cette échec s'il s'y refuse nous le
contrats par la demande de référendum
d'initiative partagée que nous avons
lancé monsieur Macron lors de son
interview assipidé inutile affirme
choisir l'intérêt général en réalité
entre le peuple et l'intérêt des riches
il a choisi l'intérêt des riches demain
sera une formidable journée cette
journée ou un peuple unie une foule
immense légitime se lèvera pour défendre
sa condition pour défendre ses droits
madame la Première ministre est encore
temps retirer votre projet merci
monsieur la parole est au ministre du
Travail je suis Olivier du soft vous
avez la parole
merci à Monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame
sénatrice griom oui le projet de loi
pourtant réforme des retraites est allée
au bout de son cheminement démocratique
et il va continuer à y aller ce projet
de loi fait suite à quatre mois de
concertation il a fait l'objet de plus
de 175 heures de débat l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat et votre assemblée
le Sénat la voté à deux reprises une
première fois en première lecture après
l'examen de chacun des articles et une
seconde fois après que la commission
mixte paritaire est trouvée une
conclusion partagée c'est la
démonstration de cette aller au bout et
si l'Assemblée nationale n'a pu voter en
première lecture c'est uniquement par
l'obstruction systématique et organisée
par les groupes de gauche qui ont privé
l'Assemblée nationale de sa capacité à
délibérer ce projet de loi il est
nécessaire madame la sénatrice
nécessaire pour faire face à déficit
structurels nécessaires pour améliorer
le système de retraite et sa mise en
oeuvre à la fin de l'année lorsque le
Conseil constitutionnel ce sera prononcé
permettra de revaloriser les petites
pensions de mieux prendre en compte la
pénibilité mais aussi de mieux
accompagner celles et ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler
vous avez parlé à deux reprises de
responsabilité la responsabilité c'est
de prendre cette de faire cette réforme
de prendre la décision d'aller au bout
de cette réforme pour sauver le système
et faire en sorte que les générations
qui viennent puissent accéder à un
système de retraite qui les protège et
qui justement protégera les plus
fragiles et puis la responsabilité
madame le sénatrice c'est que lorsque la
mobilisation sociale est organisée
lorsqu'elle se passe bien il faut la
saluer mais lorsqu'il y a des violences
il faut les condamner et quand on
condamne les violences faites la
médecinatrice on soutient les forces de
police on soutient les forces de police
placées sur l'autorité du ministre de
l'Intérieur et je profite de votre
question pour saluer leur travail je
salue l'ensemble des forces de police et
de gendarmerie qui par leur intervention
garantissent la sécurité le maintien de
l'ordre c'est aussi l'expression de la
démocratie et la liberté
la parole de notre collègue Julien
barjoton pour le groupe du Rassemblement
des démocrates progressifs et
indépendants vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse c'est
madame la ministre de la transition
énergétique madame la ministre une
surconsommation et un surdéveloppement
vampirique une exploitation non durable
des ressources en eau la pollution et le
réchauffement climatique incontrôlée
sont en train d'épuiser goutte
après-goutte cette source de vie pour
l'humanité ainsi s'exprime Antonio
gutieres dans le rapport qui va ouvrir
cette session inédite de l'ONU consacrée
à l'eau qui débute aujourd'hui les
inondations au Pakistan en 2022 nous ont
montré les conséquences sur le cycle de
l'eau du réchauffement de notre planète
33 millions de personnes concernées 1700
morts 1,8 millions d'hectares de terres
agricoles dévastées le sixième rapport
de synthèse du GIEC montrent que ces
épisodes seront de plus en plus intenses
et de plus en plus récurrents sous nos
latitudes dans notre pays
historiquement sec que nous venons de
traverser nous montre qu'il est plus que
jamais nécessaire de préserver cette
ressource qui est un des enjeux
principaux de notre siècle ces
impératifs nous pressent donc de
modifier notre rapport à l'eau nos modes
de gestion afin d'en assurer sa qualité
sa quantité et son caractère
renouvelable cette incertitude implique
également de replacer l'eau au cœur de
tous nos débats sur les changements
climatiques le gouvernement a annoncé
dévoilé prochainement 50 mesures
relatives à la gestion relative à la
gestion de l'eau alors dans le cadre de
cette journée de l'eau pour l'ONU madame
la ministre pouvez-vous nous en dire
davantage sur le contenu de ces
propositions afin de renforcer
d'améliorer la gestion de l'eau dans
notre pays pour en rassurer la qualité
et la quantité pour nos concitoyens
merci beaucoup pour vous répondre la
parole
de la transition énergétique vous avez
la parole madame la ministre merci
mon collègue Christophe bichu ministre
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires qui comme vous
le savez est fortement investi sur ce
sujet et qui rencontrera dans les
prochains jours
Antonio Guterres précisément pour porter
un agenda sur l'eau qui soit
particulièrement ambitieux tant en plan
international Coplan national vous avez
raison également de mentionner le
rapport du GIEC qui confirme l'extrême
urgence à agir pour atteindre les
objectifs de l'accord de Paris en
matière climatique
ce rapport il invite à l'action et cette
action nous l'avons prise en main sous
l'égide de la du président de la
République et de la première ministre je
rappelle que le premier quinquennat du
président de la République a permis de
doubler le rythme de baisse de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
nous continuons à agir je ne reviendrai
pas sur le vote très large sur ces bancs
de la loi énergie renouvelable et du
projet de loi une nucléaire qui sont
autant d'éléments pour pour notre
planète et lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique s'agissant de
la ressource en eau cette ressource est
un enjeu majeur en France nous devons
collectivement état comme collectivités
locales mieux anticiper la diminution de
la ressource en eau mieux préparé les
sécheresses à venir c'est tout l'objet
du plan o que la première ministre et
Christophe Béchu présenteront très
prochainement et qui est une brique
importante de l'ensemble de la
planification écologique voulue par le
président de la République nous devons
engager une réelle transition sur trois
axes la sobriété de nos usages ça fera
écho à la sobriété énergétique la
garantie de l'accès inopotable de
qualité et la restauration du grand
cycle de l'eau ce travail s'inscrit dans
la continuité des assises de l'eau et du
varen agricole il s'agit à l'échelle des
territoires de concilier d'un côté une
moindre disponibilité la ressource et de
l'autre des besoins crus ce sujet est
attendu des Français et je peux vous le
dire le gouvernement sera au rendez-vous
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame la Présidente
Laurence Rossignol pour le groupe
socialiste merci écologiste républicains
merci monsieur le Président que nous a
dit le président de la République tout à
l'heure d'abord il nous a dit que la
majorité du pays celle qui s'oppose à sa
réforme serait dans le déni de la
réalité et dans l'ignorance et que lui
seul nous conduirait vers la lumière
c'est une insulte une insulte à
l'intelligence des Français il nous a
dit que les manifestants seraient
noyautées par des factieux il est allé
jusqu'à les comparer au suprématistes de
Brasilia ou du Capitole c'est encore une
insulte il nous a dit que les syndicats
auraient refusé de négocier ça c'est un
mensonge a déjà répondu Laurent Berger
il nous a dit que nous n'aurions eu
comme contre proposition que
l'augmentation des déficits alors que
aucun de nos amendements n'a été retenu
ni même examiné y compris se tenant aux
cotisations patronales
c'est donc encore un mensonge il nous a
dit que les entreprises ne financaient
pas les retraites alors là j'ai cherché
et je n'ai vu qu'une seule explication
il a été trahi par son inconscient et en
réalité c'est son rêve mais c'est aussi
un mensonge encore
il nous a dit que les Français ne
voudraient plus travailler et qu'il
remettraient les bénéficiaires du RSA au
travail c'est une insulte à la crise
démocratique qu'il a approfondie à la
crise politique qu'il a ouverte il a
répondu par quoi la perspective de
nouveau débauchages sans doute les
députés qui n'ont pas voté la motion de
censure ça c'est une indécence il nous a
dit vouloir taxer les entreprises qui
rachètent leurs actions sauvez
l'éducation la santé l'industrie sans
jamais préciser ni ou ni corni comment
en revanche il n'a pas manqué de nous
dire que la réforme des retraites serait
appliquée sans délai alors madame la
Première ministre de matinal en 20h en
13h vous le président de la République
vos ministres vous ne faites qu'à scéner
les mêmes arguments d'autorité la seule
autocritique que vous vous concédez
c'est celle d'une défaillance
pédagogique vous voulez apaiser le pays
je ne crois sincèrement mais il n'y a
qu'une solution rendez aux Français les
deux ans de vie que vous leur voulez
la parole
est au ministre des légumes en charge du
renouveau démocratique porte-parole du
gouvernement monsieur Véran
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs Madame la
Ministre
Laurent Rossignol je vous appelle pardon
je vous appelais madame la ministre
parce que en 2014 vous étiez ministre
délégué auprès de Marisol Touraine
j'ai été député socialiste
[Applaudissements]
et vous et moi nous avons eu le courage
de soutenir en 2014 une réforme des
retraites portées par le gouvernement
socialiste auquel vous apparteniez et
que j'ai donc soutenu comme
parlementaire socialiste et qui a
pardonné moi du peu allongé la durée de
cotisation pour tous les Français qui
travaillent et vous l'avez fait dans un
souci de justice et vous l'avez fait
avec un objectif équilibré un système de
retraite qui ne l'était plus dans la
durée alors je vous dis ça madame la
sénatrice je pourrais aussi vous
rappeler qu'à l'époque lorsque vous
faisiez partie du gouvernement il y a eu
l'adoption d'un texte important
courageux nécessaire pour l'économie
notre pays adopté par un 49.3 vous étiez
au gouvernement vous ne l'avez pas
quitté j'étais alors député du groupe
socialiste je ne l'ai pas quitté comme
quoi madame
comme quoi je l'ai dit socialiste comme
quoi ça veut dire que vous avez sans
doute la mémoire sélective moi par
Madame c'est la triche il se trouve
aussi qu'en écoutant votre question j'ai
l'impression que vous avez l'oreille
sélective moi pas ou plutôt l'oreille
déformante jamais le président de la
République n'a comparé les
manifestations avec des factions à aucun
moment il a fait le distinguo entre les
manifestations démocratiques dont il a
salué la qualité de l'organisation et la
sécurisation par les organisations
syndicales il la distingué de groupes
oui madame la sédatrice de violents qui
viennent de l'ultra gauche et qui
sergent qui cherche à saccager nos
villes mais surtout même la sénatrice
parce que nous venons du même bord quand
on vous dit qu'on va augmenter les
petits salaires en dessous du SMIC vous
devez dire oui quand on dit qu'on va
améliorer les fins de carrière pour les
salariés vous devez dire oui quand on
vous dit qu'on va lever une contribution
exceptionnelle pour les grands groupes
quand il rachète des actions vous
devriez dire oui et quand on propose de
conclure de bénéficiaires du RSA loin de
l'emploi en formation ou à l'emploi vous
devriez applaudir avec nous et madame la
sénatrice c'est ça avoir de la mémoire
et du courage et de la conviction dans
la continuité
madame Rossignol non
la parole est à notre collègue Ghislaine
Portel pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen merci
monsieur le président madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire
sécheresse hivernale historique
inflation difficulté de transmission des
exploitations élevage pastoraux en péril
prédation la vulnérabilité du monde
agricole est perceptible dans les
discussions à bâton rompu que nous
pouvons avoir avec les professionnels du
secteur
les réponses apportées par les autorités
sont parfois insatisfaisantes et suscite
l'agacement l'anxiété ou la résignation
s'ajoutent à cela l'équation complexe
sur les contours du futur dispositif
d'affichage environnemental sur les
produits alimentaires
initiés par la loi relative à la lutte
contre le gaspillage et à l'économie
circulaire remodelée par la loi climat
et résilience
ce projet d'envergure fait l'objet d'un
travail de concertation piloté par
l'ADEME et le ministère de la transition
écologique qui ont collecté des
contributions jusqu'au 10 mars dernier
notamment sur les modalités d'affichage
l'analyse du cycle de vie et la méthode
d'évaluation privilégiée pour classer
les produits ou les services en fonction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
des atteintes à la biodiversité et de la
consommation d'eau et d'autres
ressources naturelles
en découle l'attribution d'une note qui
sera affichée sur les produits ou
services en rayonnage ou sur Internet
bien que cela réponde à une aspiration
légitime des consommateurs bon nombre de
producteurs craignent que cela soit
inadapté à des produits locaux et
artisanaux à l'image de ce qui avait été
observé avec le nuque avec le nutriscor
pardon
la demande des exploitants agricoles est
simple n'engendrez pas de nouvelles
sources de découragement
ainsi Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous
nous assurer que le nouvel outil
d'affichage environnemental ne
présentera pas les mêmes défaillances
que le nutriscor à l'égard de produits
du terroir je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est à Madame
Dominique Faure ministre délégué en
charge des collectivités territoriales
et de la ruralité
monsieur le Président merci mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Pantel les ministres
Christophe Béchu et Bérengère Couillard
étant en ce jour à la Conférence des
Nations Unies sur l'eau à New York il
vous prie de bien vouloir les excuser
pour la absence et me charge de répondre
à votre question la transition
écologique comme vous le savez est au
cœur de l'action gouvernementale et la
planification écologique est une
priorité de notre première ministre
l'information du consommateur et vous
l'avez souligné sur les caractéristiques
environnementales des produits qu'ils
achètent et fondamental pour faire
évoluer nos modes de consommation nous
voulons et nous devons permettre aux
consommateurs de devenir des consonnes
acteurs c'est la raison pour laquelle la
loi climat est résilience a prévu la
mise en place d'un affichage
environnemental des produits cette
affichage intégrera les enjeux d'impact
liés à la fabrication au transport des
produits en tenant compte des ressources
extraites de la consommation d'eau des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ou
encore des impacts sur la biodiversité
alors vous questionnez la méthode
plusieurs expérimentations ont été
conduites en 2021 pour les produits
alimentaires et en 2022 pour les
vêtements textils ma collègue Bérengère
Couillard a réuni dès le mois d'octobre
2022 les associations de consommateurs
les ONG et les porteurs de ces
expérimentations pour recueillir leurs
attentes et leurs idées pour construire
ensemble cette affichage environnemental
une priorité a été donnée aux produits
alimentaires et aux vêtements textiles
l'objectif est de proposer pour ces deux
secteurs n'affichage environnemental qui
pourra être déployés dès le début de
l'année 2024 par les entreprises
volontaires avant de devenir obligatoire
comme le prévoit la loi concernant plus
spécifiquement le secteur alimentaire
pas de découragement pas de défaillance
ma collègue Bérengère Couillard réunira
les parties prenantes le 27 mars
prochain pour lancer une véritable
concertation sur la première version du
projet de méthode de calcul de
l'affichage environnemental des produits
alimentaires je vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Baptiste blanc pour le groupe les
républicains
monsieur le président
ma question s'adressait à Monsieur le
Ministre Christophe Béchu le ecna s'est
livré depuis près d'un an un travail
patient et minutieux de travail et
d'écoute et d'expertise du zan c'était
édifice au nombre vices cachés au terme
d'une maturation collective et
transpartisane ça rime nous avons avec
Valérie Letard et la commission spéciale
la semaine dernière fait adopter à une
large majorité une proposition de loi
d'initiatives sénatoriale qui consolide
les fondations et confort tout l'ouvrage
pour qu'il puisse traverser le temps il
faut le répéter face aux mauvais procès
qui sont faits à notre texte le Sénat
n'a pas bouleversé l'architecture du zan
les cibles les trajectoires sont
intactes des ajustements de la souplesse
des outils nouveaux étaient nécessaires
pour répondre aux inquiétudes voir à la
colère de certains élus locaux nous les
avons écoutés et prises au sérieux
longtemps muet sur le sujet le
gouvernement dit aujourd'hui être prêt à
adapter la loi il a longtemps
sous-estimé sous-estime encore le
potentiel hautement inflammable du zan
son approche comptable est
recentralisatrice et l'absence
d'accompagnement des collectivités face
à ces nouvelles obligations inquiète les
élus de tous les départements et ici sur
tous les banc s nos auditions nous ont
convaincu qu'il était impératif
d'apporter des réponses législatives à
des questions aussi variées que le
calendrier les grands projets la prise
en compte les efforts passés la garantie
rurale les communittorale les bâtiments
agricoles il fallait éteindre l'incendie
madame la ministre le texte nous avons
rédigé est largement adopté aujourd'hui
prêt à être examiné par l'Assemblée
nationale ma question est simple
tiendrez-vous votre promesse de
poursuivre la discussion sur la base du
texte adopté par le Sénat quand le texte
sera-t-il inscrit à l'Assemblée
nationale
bon vous répondre la parole état la
ministre déléguée chargée des
collectivités de territoriales et de la
ruralité merci monsieur le président
mesdames sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
blanc monsieur le rapporteur alors vous
le savez quelques mots avant de vous
dire oui mais quelques mots quand même
vous le savez chaque année 20000
hectares d'espace naturel agricoles et
forestiers sont consommés en moyenne en
France les conséquences de ce phénomène
sont écologique vous le savez mais c'est
aussi socio-économique notamment la
diminution du potentiel de production
agricole alors comme vous l'avez rappelé
la France est fixée cet objectif
d'atteindre à horizon de 2050 le 0
artificialisation net et un objectif
intermédiaire de réduction de moitié et
fixé à 2030 pour la consommation
d'espace naturel agricole forestier dans
les 10 prochaines années alors en
novembre dernier l'onde lors de son
discours de clôture du Congrès des
Maires madame la Première ministre a
rappelé que le gouvernement était prêt
un certain nombre d'évolution dont la
prise en compte des grands projets
d'envergure national et puis cette
garantie rurale à laquelle nous sommes
tous attachés les propositions du
gouvernement ont été défendues par
Christophe bessut de l'examen de la PPL
sénatoriale sur le zan la semaine
dernière vous le savez monsieur le
rapporteur et non pas été retenu par le
Sénat qui a préféré ce que nous pensons
être une trajectoire moins économe en
termes d'artificialisation le
gouvernement considère aujourd'hui que
le texte du Sénat ne permet pas de
respecter la trajectoire ambitieuse de
réduction d'artificialisation que nous
portons et qui est fixé par la loi
climat et résilience alors cependant
monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
rapporteur cette proposition de loi
encore vocation à évoluer dans le cadre
de la navette parlementaire si
l'objectif est de parvenir à un
compromis acceptable pour l'ensemble des
acteurs que ce soit les députés les
sénateurs les associations d'élus locaux
ou les associations ou de défense de
l'environnement sur ce sujet aussi
important pour les Français comme pour
les élus locaux le gouvernement reste
très attaché à trouver un compromis
acceptable pour tous nous allons trouver
ensemble ce compromis monsieur le
rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez la
parole
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
ne peut pas vous laisser dire que nous
nous sortons de la trajectoire nous
sommes dans la trajectoire je le dis le
redis madame Letare Opin du chef voilà
au contraire nous pensons que seuls les
élus locaux pour remporter la transition
écologique et Lausanne faut juste leur
donner du temps des moyens des outils de
l'ingénierie proposant des choses
simples et encore une fois c'est très
hautement inflammable il faut écouter le
Sénat
la parole est à notre collègue Jean-Yves
Leconte pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre madame et messieurs et mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse aux
ministres de l'Intérieur la France est
dans la rue pour manifester son
désaccords profonds avec le passage en
force d'une réforme des retraites
qu'elle rejette en bloc d'une réforme
qui n'est pas soutenable d'un point de
vue humain et social et dont le poids
repose exclusivement sur les efforts des
travailleurs des travailleurs c'est dans
ce contexte très tendu qui était prévu
l'examen dans l'hémicycle du Sénat le
projet de loi immigration et intégration
à compter de mardi prochain alors que
les droits des étrangers en France sont
déjà particulièrement dégradés qu'ils
sont soumis à des conditions de plus en
plus exigeantes à des procédures
toujours plus complexes qu'il les
maintiennent dans des situations de
précarité et d'insécurité juridique
administrative inacceptable une réforme
de leurs droits mérite d'être abordé
avec sérénité et sérieux
c'est pourquoi au vu du contexte le
groupe socialiste écologique et
républicain demandait le retrait de ce
projet de loi de l'ordre du jour de
notre assemblée monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous préciser les propos du
président de la République qui semblent
annoncer une série de textes découpant
votre projet de loi façon puzzle quoi
qu'il arrive le gouvernement peut et
doit prendre rapidement les mesures qui
s'imposent concernant la régularisation
des travailleurs étrangers il n'est pas
besoin d'une loi pour réviser au plus
vite la liste des métiers en tension
dans le cadre d'une concertation avec
les partenaires sociaux concertation ni
pour donner des instructions aux préfets
en faveur de l'administration de
l'admission au séjour des étrangers qui
contribuent chaque jour à l'effort
national et cotise pour nos retraites
ainsi dans l'attente de mesures
législatives permettant de sécuriser
durablement leur séjour et leur emploi
il convient de ne pas les maintenir dans
une situation inadmissible de précarité
et d'agir rapidement avec les outils
existants monsieur le ministre qu'attend
donc le gouvernement pour agir sur ses
urgences
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de l'intérieur des Outre-mer
monsieur Darmanin merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur de compte
vous avez bien entendu le président de
la République je vous remercie d'avoir
d'en faire écho de ces propositions ici
puisque nous avons en effet entendu le
Sénat monsieur le Président du Sénat du
même exprimé lors de sa rencontre avec
le président de la République je crois
savoir je suis un échange avec le
président buffet la commission des lois
et bien évidemment nous entendons votre
demande et c'est pour cela que le
premier ministre dans quelques instants
va avec le ministre des Parlement et
monsieur le ministre du Travail et
moi-même proposé une méthode de travail
au Parlement à la semaine nationale et
au Sénat pour adopter des mesures
législatives qui sont nécessaires pour
évidemment améliorer l'intégration mais
également lutter contre l'immigration
irrégulière la lutte contre les passeurs
l'intégration évidemment par la langue
l'intégration par le travail les
délinquants étrangers que nous devons
plus facilement expulser mais aussi les
moyens donnés à notre droit à nos
préfectures je crois que nous sommes
tous d'accord pour dire que c'est à la
fois législatif et extrêmement
nécessaire cependant nous avons entendu
la nouvelle méthode de travail voulue
par le président de la République et par
les chambres parlementaires un
enregistré le soin à la première
ministre d'évoquer avec les prisons de
chambre sur le texte qui me concerne et
qui concerne du socle d'immigration mais
sur tous les autres textes la même
méthode qu'elle aura elle-même définie
j'espère aussi avoir répondu à votre
interrogation
monsieur le
compte merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie de
ces précisions mais s'il y avait s'il y
a une volonté politique en particulier
sur l'intégration par le travail ce que
vous pouvez faire ce que vous pouviez
faire depuis 2017 depuis 2022 commencé à
le faire maintenant avant même de change
on n'a pas besoin de modifications
législatives pour un certain nombre de
choses la liste des métiers en tension
l'admission l'admission exceptionnelle
au séjour allez-y montrez-nous vous avez
sur ce sujet une volonté politique et
pas simplement des
la parole est à notre collègue Antoine
Lefebvre pour le groupe les républicains
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de la Santé de la
prévention monsieur le ministre le 13
mars dernier les 10000 étudiants en 6e
année de médecine était appelé à passer
en centre d'examen des épreuves blanches
en prévision du concours d'entrée à
l'internat prévu en juin prochain
organisé par le Centre national de
gestion qui répondent la tutelle de
votre ministère les épreuves ont vite
tournées au fiasco bug à répétition
impossibilité de valider les réponses
ralentissement problème d'affichage
voire carrément déconnexion en cours
d'épreuve à tout juste trois mois des
véritables épreuves classantes
nationales qui sont décisives dans le
pour le choix de la spécificité la
spécialité et du lieu d'exercice ce coût
décès constitué pourtant une occasion
privilégiée pour les étudiants de se
situer par rapport au niveau national et
de tester en réel les conditions qui les
attendaient
en outre le concours répondait à de
nouvelles règles d'organisations suivant
une méthodologie inédite les étudiants
ne disposaient donc pas d'annales des
examens précédents ni de support pour
s'entraîner les réponses du CNG sont
tout aussi lunaires plutôt que d'assumer
la responsabilité d'un dysfonctionnement
sur le système informatique le centre
préfère minimiser le problème et
d'accuser une incompréhension sémantique
suggérant que les épreuves n'auraient
pas été un vrai concours blanc mais bien
un simple test pour vérifier la
performance du logiciel on croit rêver
l'association des étudiants en médecine
de France demande à ce que de nouvelles
épreuves blanches puissent être
organisées dans les meilleurs délais sur
une plateforme fiable et opérationnelle
à trois mois des épreuves de classement
national qui détermineront toute la
carrière de nos futurs médecins quant
allez-vous enfin mener une politique
ambitieuse d'investissement dans les
moyens mis à disposition de nos
étudiants pouvez-vous garantir la totale
fiabilité du support numérique des
épreuves d'ici à juin merci
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
monsieur Braun
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Lefebvre heureusement
heureusement que cette panne a eu lieu
le 13 mars dernier parce que comme vous
l'avez dit c'était une épreuve blanche
mais une épreuve blanche sous les
étudiants n'était de toute façon pas
classés parce qu'il n'avait pas
évaluation de leur réponse c'était bien
une épreuve blanche pour tester cette
nouvelle plateforme informatique qui
répond aux évolutions du deuxième cycle
des études médicales et comme vous
l'avez très bien dit qui est nouvelle
donc cette épreuve a été interrompue et
la fonctionné pour 85% des étudiants
mais effectivement un pourcentage sur
cette première épreuve n'a pas pu être
il n'arrivait pas à valider leur
résultat alors que s'est-il passé après
cette épreuve blanche et bien les
corrections étaient apportées le
lendemain 97% des bugs si je peux
exprimer ainsi était réglé et comme nous
n'étions pas à 100% et c'est essentiel
pour valider la plateforme de test nous
avons préféré reporter le deuxième
passage de cette épreuve blanche je le
rappelle sans classement des étudiants
il n'aurait pas les résultats de toute
façon de leur réponse ce n'était qu'un
test technique donc la deuxième partie
qui devait avoir lieu le 15 mars a été
annulé bien entendu le CNG a travaillé à
corriger aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
difficultés il y aura une nouvelle
épreuve blanche qui se déroulera fin
avril début mai pour que au mois de juin
le résultat soit sans discussion que
cette épreuve puisse être réalisée car
comme vous l'avez très bien dit elle est
primordiale pour les étudiants en
médecine puisqu'elle préjuge de leur
avenir professionnel et du choix de leur
spécialité donc ce test a eu lieu il a
bien eu lieu comme tous les tests et ça
aussi c'est de la prévention nous avons
constaté des difficultés elles sont
corrigées il y aura un nouveau test
avant de pouvoir mettre cette plateforme
totalement opérationnelle en juin je
vous remercie
monsieur le ministre nos étudiants en
médecine ont connu beaucoup de
déconvenue dans cette période avec des
confinements à répétition des
enseignements à distance et du stress il
méritent davantage de considération la
France a un besoin urgent nouveau
médecin tout le long de le sait ici
particulièrement au Sénat nous devons
tout mettre en oeuvre pour réussir que
les chances de réussite soit de leur
côté merci
la parole est à notre collègue Jacques
le nez pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
ce que les élus ne supportent plus c'est
de servir de défouloir ces mots sont
ceux du président l'Association des
Maires du Morbihan prononcer lors de la
présentation des chiffres des démissions
intervenues depuis 3 ans la situation
est inédite dans le département
4 élus municipaux d'émissionnent chaque
semaine depuis 2020 le mandat local
n'attire plus le Morbihan n'est pas une
exception en Loire-Atlantique un élu
local d'émission de chaque jour et nous
savons que le phénomène est national
plusieurs constats concours à ces
désengagements les élus subissent des
violences de tout nature physique
verbale via les réseaux sociaux et trop
souvent les plaintes sont classées sans
suite les élus sont résignées et
exaspérés l'empilement des normes la
lourdeur administrative décourage et
bonne volonté même les plus motivés ont
du mal à concilier vie professionnelle
et mandat un mandat chronophage est mal
indemnisé enfin le maire voire réduire
ses compétences propres alors que
l'urbanisme constitue un ultime élément
d'attractivité de la fonction
l'objectif zan complexifie leur mission
c'est un dernier coup de massue sur un
engagement déjà mal en point au-delà de
cette vague de démission la question se
pose sur la capacité même à maintenir un
fonctionnement régulier des
collectivités et à pourvoir aux
fonctions d'élus madame la Première
ministre comment comptez-vous redonner
des moyens et du sens au mandat de maire
et plus généralement à celui d'élus
local ils sont les premiers remparts et
les garants des fondements de notre
démocratie
pour vous répondre la parole
et Olivier Véran porte-parole du
gouvernement devait la parole monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Jacques
le nez
vous avez raison de le souligner d'abord
la France a besoin de l'engagement de
ces élus locaux on en a un besoin
absolument vital il y a pas de vie
communale pas de vie départementale
régionale sans l'action déterminée des
liloko et on le sait je suis convaincu
que les Français elles savent aussi ce
qui fonde l'engagement des élus locaux
c'est pas certainement pas la pas du
gain ou la gloriole que ça pourrait
apporter c'est un engagement au service
des autres on est d'accord je fais
j'ouvre là je fais là un euphémisme et
c'est dur d'être élu local
qui se réveille à 5h du matin quand la
neige est tombée un peu trop fort cette
nuit et que les routes sont encombrées
c'est le maire
qui doit intervenir lorsque des conflits
de vaginage peuvent dégénérer c'est le
maire qui est pris entre les injonctions
paradoxales et contradictoires parfois
vous l'avez dit vous-même avec des
normes qui s'imposent depuis Paris et la
difficulté des applications le
territoire c'est les mères alors la
moindre des choses qu'on puisse faire
c'est offrir la protection que les élus
locaux méritent dans une France qui
constate jour après jour la montée de la
violence sur les réseaux sociaux parfois
la violence verbale parfois jusque dans
les hémicycles
et parfois de la violence physique
également il était indispensable d'agir
alors des choses ont été faites en 2019
nous avons renforcé le régime de
protection des élus qui s'apparente
désormais à la protection fonctionnelle
applicable aux agents publics notamment
lorsque un élu fait l'objet de poursuite
pour des fautes qui sont détachables de
ces fonctions ou alors lorsqu'il est
victime de violence ou d'outrage à
l'occasion ou du fait de ses fonctions
sous protection qui peut également être
accordée à leur demande au conjoint
enfant ascendant direct des élus qui
seraient décédés dans l'exercice ou de
fêtes de leur fonction à raison des
faits à l'origine de ce décès c'est pas
un fonctionnement très lourd c'est pas
un financement très lourd et donc la loi
le corps nu ensuite créé l'obligation de
souscrire à une garantie qui permet de
couvrir au-delà de ça le conseil
juridique l'assistance psychologique les
coûts qui résultent de l'obligation pour
les communes de protection fonctionnelle
des membres de conseil municipal c'est
un dispositif qui rend ainsi plus
effective moins risqué la mise en oeuvre
de la protection fonctionnelle par les
communes il a eu lapl Delattre aussi et
puis ma collègue Dominique force elle
avait été là vous aurez raconté comment
nous allons créer une cellule d'analyse
et de lutte contre les atteintes aux
élus locaux au sein du ministère de
l'Intérieur croyant notre détermination
pour avancer en l'occurrence et en la
matière et on avancera avec vous
monsieur le nez et merci monsieur le
ministre si rien n'est fait cette
situation contribuera à la crise
profonde que connaissent nos
institutions car ne l'oublions pas le
maire et le représentant de l'État sur
sa commune
la parole est à notre collègue Philippe
mzec pour le groupe les républicains
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs les
ministres la terre d'Arménie brûle et
nous regardons ailleurs
depuis l'automne 2020 l'Arménie est en
état de siège depuis l'invasion de
l'enclave arménienne Larzac par l'armée
d'Azerbaïdjan soutenu par la Turquie qui
s'en sert comme avant garde pour
poursuivre et achever l'éradication du
peuple arménien entamé en 1915 entre les
épisodes de guerre civile qui a déjà
fait 5000 morts et 15000 blessés en
trois ans c'est un véritable blocus
orchestré par l'Azerbaïdjan pour
empêcher les vivre et les médicaments
d'arriver jusque dans l'enclave
arménienne les seuls qui est le droit de
passage sont les Arméniens qui fuient la
guerre la famine et la misère mais ils
n'ont droit qu'à un aller simple
l'Azerbaïdjan comptant sur le départ des
120 000 Arméniens restants pour poser
définitivement son joug sur ce
territoire
et ce n'est qu'une première étape pour
rayer de la carte cette terre chrétienne
quelle Arménie la plus ancienne du monde
aujourd'hui encerclé par l'expansion
musulmane depuis nos villes des
Hauts-de-Seine qui accueillent une forte
communauté d'origine arménienne nous
envoyons des vives des médicaments et
aussi des médecins en partenariat avec
lumière française
ainsi nous essayons de forcer le blocus
mais qu'attend le gouvernement au-delà
des messages d'amitié pour demander le
respect des règles internationales et du
droit des peuples l'Arménie ce petit
pays porte les mêmes valeurs que les
nôtres alors c'est vrai que l'Arménie ce
n'est pas l'Ukraine on y trouve ni
pétrole ni gaz contrairement à
l'Azerbaïdjan l'Arménie n'a rien hormis
sa foi et son courage ma question est la
ministre et donc de savoir si la France
est prête à mobiliser les mêmes moyens
diplomatiques voire militaire
qu'on l'a fait pour l'Ukraine pour
défendre en Arménie un peuple ami qui
est en train de mourir merci
[Musique]
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame la Ministre de l'Europe et les
affaires étrangères madame Colonna merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Balzac merci de votre question
car il permet de rappeler que depuis le
premier jour c'est-à-dire depuis le 12
décembre la France dénonce le blocage du
corridor latin par l'Azerbaïdjan et ses
conséquences tentent économiques
humanitaires en effet la population
depuis cette date ne peut plus circuler
librement les vivre arrivent
de façon parcimonieuse et grâce au
Comité international de la Croix-Rouge
que la France aide monsieur le sénateur
ainsi que ses partenaires de l'Union
européenne alors oui cette situation ne
peut plus durer la libre circulation
doit être rétablie sans tarder et
l'approvisionnement des populations du
haut Karaba doit être mieux assurée
d'abord parce que c'est le droit et je
les dis ici je veux le rappeler la Cour
internationale de justice c'est prononcé
par référé il y a quelques semaines et
ensuite parce que ce blocage alimente
les tensions éloignent les perspectives
de règlement politique qui est le seul
possible donc un accord de paix que nous
recherchons et que l'Arménie recherche
monsieur sénateur avec son voisin je
prévois de me rendre à Baco et à Yerevan
Coran avril pour porter ce message pour
rappeler la nécessité d'une solution
politique pour rappeler la nécessité
d'abord du CCF auquel les deux parties
se sont engagés et pour souligner que
les menaces d'emploi de la force sont
inacceptables je le redis monsieur
sénateur nous sommes déterminés je suis
déterminé et la France agit elle ne
regarde pas ailleurs elle agit elle ne
parle pas je vous remercie merci la
parole est à notre
collègue Angèle Préville pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues à l'aube du
lancement d'un grand programme nucléaire
dans notre pays vous avez proposé par
amendement à l'Assemblée nationale la
fusion de l'IRSN et de la SN ou
peut-être plutôt l'absorption de l'IRSN
par la s.n cette loi qui propose tout un
panel de mécanismes dit d'accélération
avait déjà été examiné au Sénat sans cet
amendement quel drôle d'idée quand on a
un parc vieillissant nécessitant toute
notre attention et un programme très
ambitieux de 8 voire 14 voire plus
encore de nouveaux réacteurs fort
heureusement les députés plus
raisonnables l'ont rejeté dois-je
rappeler quand la matière nous ne sommes
à l'abri de rien dans le pays le plus
nucléarisé au monde nous pouvons
remercier tous les jours notre sûreté
car nous n'avons pas eu jusque là
d'accidents nucléaires l'IRSN est
indépendant exerce des fonctions
d'expertise et de recherche qu'il
fournit à la SN et c'est la SN en tant
qu'autorité qui prend les décisions
c'est basique c'est efficace et c'est
une nécessité absolue pourquoi casser ce
qui fonctionne pourquoi provoquer de la
confusion voire du désordre les salariés
de l'URSS sont d'ailleurs sous le choc
chaos debout sur quelle étude d'impact
d'ailleurs repose ce choix l'arrêt de 4
réacteurs à l'automne suite à la
détection de corrosion sous contrainte
pour lequel on a agité le spectre du
placard a-t-il agacé a-t-il provoqué
lire qui se résumerait à la sûreté ça
suffit comme ça nous sommes au printemps
il n'y a pas eu de blackout mais de
nouvelles corrosion ont été découvertes
la réalité c'est que plus que jamais
nous avons besoin d'organismes robustes
ayant largement fait leur preuve et même
reconnu internationalement notre
boussole en matière du nucléaire doit
être cette aigu conscience des périls
dont parle et garorin votre vent votre
volonté d'effacement de l'URSS a été
sèchement rejetée par l'Assemblée
nationale elle est non seulement
malvenue mais surtout dangereuse on se
doute que vous n'allez pas lâcher prise
puisque c'est l'ADN de ce gouvernement
madame la ministre sur ce sujet comme
sur les autres gouverner est-ce santé
la parole de calaministes de la
transition énergétique qu'on a prévenir
une HP
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Préville en matière
énergétique le président de la
République a un objectif ambitieux faire
de la France le premier grand pays a
sorti des énergies fossiles et à
reprendre en main notre destin
énergétique c'est dans ce contexte que
le gouvernement travaille à un programme
nucléaire de 6 nouveaux EPR 2 et à la
mise à l'étude de 8 supplémentaires
c'est un projet pour notre indépendance
énergétique c'est un projet pour la
planète c'est un projet qui doit aussi
nous permettre de reprendre le fil de la
plus grande aventure industrielle
française depuis les années 70 le
Conseil de politique nucléaire du 3
février dernier qui s'est tenu sous
l'égide du président de la République et
de la première ministre a mis à jour la
feuille de route pour mobiliser tous les
maillons de notre filière nucléaire
c'est dans ce contexte que le
gouvernement ait décidé le renforcement
le renforcement de notre sûreté
nucléaire en avançant sur le
rapprochement de la SN et de l'URSS de
quoi s'agit-il très simplement il est
proposé d'élargir les missions de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire sur des
modèles éprouvés des autorités de sûreté
du Canada ou encore des États-Unis en
rapprochant la décision le contrôle des
missions d'expertise et de recherche il
s'agit donc au fond de réunir sous la
même manière qu'il y a le statut le plus
indépendant celui d'autorité
administrative indépendante le statut de
la SN plus indépendant que l'IRSN deux
services qui concourent au même service
public à la même mission de service
public au terme de cette réforme
l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire ou cette
composition a estagnée RSN deviendrait
la deuxième autorité de sûreté du monde
en termes de moyens humains et
financiers avec une crédibilité
scientifique renforcée nous sommes donc
bien loin des fantasmes et des modèles
que vous évoquez suite au vote hier du
projet de loi nucléaire à une très large
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale qui
demande entre autres au gouvernement un
rapport explicitant les modalités de
mise en oeuvre de cette réforme et la
vie de l'OPEX j'avancerai je demanderai
au sénateur avec mon collègue Franck
Riester les modalités selon lesquelles
le Sénat veut être associé à cette
réforme et effectivement dans la
concertation pourquoi l'intro pour la
clé
la parole est à notre collègue Damien
Rognard
pour les républicains
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre Colona mais chers collègues
après la visite du président Macron en
août 2022 en Algérie suivi de la visite
de la première ministre accompagnée de
16 de ses ministres après la visite de
Monsieur Darmanin en décembre 2022 qui
nous explique à son retour que tout va
bien et qui supprime les mesures de
limitation à 50% de délivrance de visa
pour la France il semble que nous ayons
tout lâché mais pour quel résultat les
délivrances de laisser passer consulaire
de l'Algérie pour les auqtf étaient déjà
extrêmement faibles moins de 1% et avec
le rappel de son ambassadeur en France
le 8 février 2023 l'Algérie via ses 18
consulats sur notre territoire annonce
inédits ne plus délivrer un seul laisser
passer consulaire et menace de suspendre
la délivrance des visas pour les
Français souhaitant se rendre en Algérie
je t'aime moi non plus ou en sommes-nous
madame la ministre ou en sommes-nous de
la main tendue et de cette repentance
incessante envers l'Algérie où sont les
résultats la réforme de votre ministère
qui écarte des diplomates chevronnés de
véritables négociateurs et bâtisseurs de
pont entre nos pays respectifs
commencent à faire vaciller toute un
édifice à quand des mesures fortes pour
une France forte et respectée des
mesures de restorution existent et sont
pourtant simples suspendent la
délivrance des visas aux Algériens
souhaitant se rendre en France
parallélisme des formes et égalité
traitement ni plus ni moins
[Applaudissements]
de l'Europe des Affaires étrangères
madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur
sénateur avec l'Algérie nous avons
initié une dynamique ambitieuse depuis
la visite d'amitié du président de la
République les 25 26 et 27 août 2022
suivi de la réunion du cinquième
Comité intergouvernemental de haut
niveau sous l'autorité de madame la
Première ministre et de son homologue
les 9 et 10 octobre 2022 et vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le sénateur le ministre
de l'Intérieur s'est ensuite rendu en
Algérie le 17 décembre dernier et je
note aussi vous l'avez oublié la visite
en France du chef d'état-major de
l'armée algérienne une première depuis
bien longtemps
alors monsieur le sénateur il faut
éviter de tomber dans le piège de ceux
qui souhaitent faire échouer notre
ambition ce n'est pas votre vœu j'en
suis sûr alors nous allons continuer à
travailler avec les autorités
algériennes à la levée des difficultés
constatées car la profondissement de
notre relation est dans l'intérêt de nos
deux pays et c'est dans cet esprit que
la France traite notamment de la
question de la migration entre l'Algérie
et la France cela concerne les visas
avec un groupe de travail conjoint qui
doit favoriser les mobilités notamment
entre les jeunes et en particulier les
jeunes professionnels mais cette
coopération oui pour être cohérente doit
également permettre d'assurer le retour
en Algérie des Algériens en situation
irrégulière comme le droit le commande
et ça fait partie de nos priorités
immédiates nous y travaillons nous y
travaillons notamment avec le président
teboun dont je suis sûr monsieur
sénateur que vous aurez noté avec
intérêt les dernières déclarations
si la visite du président algérien te
donne en France s'est confirmé en mai
prochain il sera toujours temps de
remettre le sujet sur la table avec
fermeté enfin je crois au porter un de
rappeler que la naïveté peut-être
considérée comme de la faiblesse non
madame la ministre nous ne voulons pas
d'une France qui se couche mais d'une
France qui se fait respecter merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue
Pierre-Antoine Lévy pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
ma question s'adressée au ministre de
l'Économie je vois qu'il est parti
monsieur le ministre en mars 2022 le
prix du baril de pétrole Brent aussi
entre 115 et 130 dollars les prix à la
pompe étaient élevés avec un litre de
gazole il y a 2,11 et un litre de sang
plombs à 2,6 en moyenne 12 mois plus
tard alors que le baril de pétrole n'a
jamais été aussi bas depuis 15 mois 75
dollars et un d'euro qui remonte les
prix des carburants ne baissent pourtant
quasiment pas ou très peu à la pompe ces
jours-ci les prix restent toujours très
élevés pour les automobilistes avec un
lit de gazoil à 1,82 et un litre de
Simplon à 1,97 € en moyenne nul besoin
d'être prix Nobel d'économie pour se
rendre compte que lorsque le prix du
baril augmente les prix augmentent très
fortement mais lorsque le prix du baril
baisse significativement les prix la
bombe ne baisse que très peu monsieur le
ministre je sais que l'on aime bien
faire des comparaisons avec des voisins
européens aussi je me suis permis de
regarder ce qui se fait dans quelques
pays Allemagne un euro 76 pour le
sans-plomb 95 un euro 73 pour le Gaso
Belgique 1,65 pour le sans-plomb 95,70
pour le gasoil Espagne 1,62 pour le
simple en 95 et 1,55 pour le gazole
comparaison n'est pas raison mais
comprenez que dans le contexte actuel de
tension économique sociale et maintenant
politique de concitoyens ont la réelle
impression de ne pas payer le juste prix
et il est évident que ce n'est pas
nouveau chèque carburant qui veut
réclame ce qu'ils veulent c'est une
vraie baisse des prix à la pompe
monsieur le ministre j'ai conscience que
les prix du carburant est un mécanisme
complexe mais il est temps que les prix
soient transparents et enfin cohérents
avec les variations du prix du baril
alors ma question est la suivante
monsieur le ministre que compte faire le
gouvernement a très court terme pour que
les prix à la pompe reflètent enfin de
manière plus visible les cours du marché
de pétrole je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
pour vos réponses la parole est au
ministre et chargé de l'Industrie
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Lévy d'abord je vous prie
d'excuser le ministre Bruno Le Maire qui
a dû qui a dû s'absenter qui m'a chargé
du coup de vous répondre en son lieu et
place vous dire ensuite vous l'avez dit
que les mécanismes de transmission du
prix du baril sur les marchés et du prêt
à la pompe sont des mécanismes complexes
qui prennent souvent un peu de temps et
qui reflète
de manière incomplète la volatilité
extrême qu'on observe sur les marchés
vous l'avez dit le baril du Brent le
prix du baril a baissé de manière très
forte la semaine dernière reflétant
essentiellement les incertitudes
financières il fait yoyo au jour le jour
c'est vrai que les prix à la pompe ne
font pas le yoyo un jour le jour et
reflète plutôt avec retard les
évolutions à la hausse à la baisse des
prix à la pompe vous l'avez dit le taux
de change entre les rôles de l'art peut
aussi avoir un impact positif ou négatif
sur le prix à la pompe je dois
reconnaître que ces derniers jours les
désorganisations dans les chaînes
d'approvisionnement peuvent conduire les
distributeurs à reconstituer des stocks
de précaution tout ceci étant évidemment
le reflet d'un certain nombre de
conflits et de blocages qui ne sont sans
doute pas très opportun pour la
simplicité de la livraison de l'essence
bref tout ça est un peu compliqué cela
dit cela dit le prix à l'essence a
baissé quand même ces derniers jours par
rapport au chiffre que vous mentionnez
on est plutôt aux alentours de 1,90 pour
le super semblant et un 80 pour le
gasoil ça commence à baisser j'espère
bien que si le prix du baril continue à
baisser le prix de l'essence ce sera
aussi ensuite votre est enfin votre
question me permet de rappeler aux
françaises et aux Français que le
gouvernement et le Parlement d'ailleurs
ont adopté un chèque de 100 euros qui
permet à 4 millions de Françaises et de
français d'ores et déjà de bénéficier
d'une facture à la pompe réduite
j'engage celles et ceux qui n'ont pas
encore réclamé ce chèque de se connecter
sur un pot.gouv.fr ça prend cinq minutes
c'est extrêmement simple et ça rapporte
gros puisque ça rapporte 100 euros merci
Monsieur Lévy
oui monsieur le ministre merci pour
votre réponse mais comme vous l'avez dit
quand le prix du baril monte le
lendemain le prix de l'essence augmente
fortement ou le surlendemain par contre
quand les prix baissent il faut attendre
plusieurs semaines avant de voir une
matérialisation à la du prix à la pompe
ce n'est pas normal j'espère que le
gouvernement pourra inciter à plus de
transparence merci merci
merci madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres nous
avons terminé avec les questions
gouvernement notre prochaine réunion
portant question d'actualité au
gouvernement aura lieu le mercredi 29
mars à 15h la séance va être suspendue
sur la reprise assez leur trône pour le
débat à la suite du dépôt du rapport
public annuel de la Cour des comptes la
séance est suspendue